Libertarian Party presidential and vice
presidential candidates Gary Johnson and
bill weld who are at about 10% in
national polls participated in a CNN
hosted Town Hall Wednesday that
introduced them to a national audience
that's barely heard of them in a year
when the electorate dislikes the major
candidates more than ever in history
they had what might have been a historic
opportunity so how did they do we are
here to tell you in three minutes
first they explained what a libertarian
is and broad brushstrokes fiscally
conservative socially accepting tolerant
look people should be able to make
choices in their own lives always come
down on the side of choice then they
played a very strange game at the past
of CNN do some word association here
I'll say the name you hit me with the
first thing that comes to mind and
tripped over themselves to be nice to
Hillary Clinton and President Obama
before attacking Trump President Barack
Obama a good good guy Hillary Clinton
old friend nice kid newer in her 20s we
shared an office on the Nixon
impeachment real bond lifelong seriously
not kidding Donald Trump one word
huckster when asked about gun control
former prosecutor bill will turn the
discussion towards a task force he put
together to treat Isis like it's the
Mafia
with a thousand person FBI task force
treating Isis is a gigantic organized
crime family which is exactly what it is
Johnson gave a defense of free market
health care if we could bring genuine
competition
to health care health care would be
one-fifth the cost of what it is right
now a non-interventionist foreign policy
we don't want to get involved in other
countries affairs we think that the
interventions that have gone on have
resulted in a less safe world not a more
safe world abortion rights that's a
decision that should lie strictly with
the woman involved and then confirm that
he believes in some sort of God but
isn't all that into organized religion
the God that that I speak to is not
doesn't have a particular religion bill
well double down on and Frank analogy to
attack Trump the rounding up in
deportation of 11 million people I mean
that's a lot of people and that's going
to engendered of fear and
hiding in the Attic hoping no noise will
alert the Nazis below speaking of weld
Johnson really really loves his VP bill
weld being my running mate is beyond my
wildest expectation hope please I hope
it's obvious
look we're proposing to do this as a
team we're not gonna have separate
staffs MIT Romney said I would have
wanted to see the ticket flipped he said
I wouldn't want to see weld on top not
to create any internet strife no none
whatsoever
there was the inevitable what if heroin
were legal question please explain to me
how you think that legalizing marijuana
straight through to heroin can possibly
be a harm reduction forum hate to say it
but it's it's prohibition it's quality
quantity unknown that kills people and
Johnson ended it all with a big middle
finger to the two-party system if it
were to come to bear fruit that you saw
that you were hurting Clinton or you
were hurting Trump and that that was
your role in this election how'd you
feel about that I'd feel just fine I do
believe that we've got the Accardi
system is a two-party dinosaur and that
they're but to come in contact with the
commentary so that's the alternative
vision the Libertarian Party has to
offer this election now back to your
regularly scheduled political
programming in the midst of the most
toxic campaign ever as chanting Democrat
Southdown Super Bowl one to 16 the
unfinished business is
consideration of the veto message of the
president on House Joint Resolution 88